- [Instructor] In this video,
we're gonna take a journey in life
and we're gonna start with
the smallest scale of life
that is indisputably life,
and that is the cell.
Now, the reason why I
qualified that a little bit
is some people debate whether
viruses are living or not,
'cause they have certain aspects.
Viruses can reproduce, they
do have genetic information
but they need other
living forms to reproduce,
in particular they need other cells.
But even though we imagined cells
to be these very small microscopic things,
they are in and of themselves
almost an entire world,
and we go into depth into
that into other videos
in Khan Academy.
But the fact that every cell in your body,
except for a few like red blood cells
have all of your genetic
information in there.
All of those 3 billion base pairs of DNA
that make you a human being
in and of itself is mind-boggling.
But then the fact that
the cell specializes
so that not all cells are the same
even though they have that
same genetic information,
they somehow know what type of cell to be
that's even more interesting.
So we could start at the
most basic building block
in your body or really any organism's body
and that's specialized cells.
So what you're seeing here
is a big cluster of neurons
which are dyed here in the red,
and I believe these blues
show their actual nuclei
where they have their genetic information.
And then dyed in green,
you have what are called
neuroglia cells which
are other types of cells
that are inside the human brain
mainly to support neurons.
Most of what we believe is thought
occurs through triggering neurons,
which then trigger other neurons
and form cascades of these
electro-chemical signals
which we're just starting to understand.
But this is just one little
small fraction of a human brain.
A human brain, for example we'll have
on the order of 80 to 90 billion neurons.
And for every one of those neurons
depending on what part of the
brain you're talking about,
you're talking about five
to 10 neuroglia cells.
So you're talking about many
hundreds of billions of cells
just in one human brain.
But then if we were to
zoom out a little bit
and you take a bunch of
these specialized cells
working together or at
least near each other,
you have tissue.
And so as I said before,
this is a zoomed in view
of neural tissue in
particular of brain tissue.
And then if you zoom
out a little bit more,
the tissue makes up organs.
And if we're thinking about
neural tissue like this,
we can imagine that it makes up the brain
which is an organ.
And then organs build up to systems.
And right over here, you have a picture
of the nervous system of
which the brain is apart.
You also have the spinal cord,
and then you also have all of the nerves
that go throughout the body.
So we have a system.
And then you put all
of the systems together
and you get the actual organism,
which of course you can somewhat
visualize right over here
where you can see all of
these different organs
and organ systems put
together to create who we are.
And just to connect to the
organism with the cells,
that basic building block of life.
If you are a average size human being,
you likely have 30 to 40
trillion cells in your body.
And if that isn't mind blowing enough
and it is just an estimate,
it's estimated that there's as many
as 100 trillion bacteria in your body.
And so even though you think
you are just "an individual"
you are a universe of living things
in these complex systems.
And it's an interesting question of why
and right over here.
We know that organisms
interact with each other.
We know that they interact
with their environment
just as each of our nerve
cells might not appreciate
that they are one of 86
billion in dissension mind,
maybe we ourselves as
organisms don't appreciate
that we too are building blocks
of maybe something even larger.